Salut, c'est Norman ! Aujourd'hui, je réponds à vos questions.
sur Twitter
J’espère qu'elles sont pertinentes
C'est parti
Toujours aussi Badass !!
Je parie que je ne passerai pas sur cette vidéo
FAUX !
Le cadeau le plus surprenant venant d'un fan
Un jour lors d'un de mes spectacles
Il y a une fille qui m'a offert ce masque de moi-même
Voilà
Donc ça m'a fait hyper plaisir mais je vois pas trop à quoi peut me servir ce masque
À part à me déguiser en moi-même
Hey ! C'est Norman
HAHAHAHA
Non je déconne. C'est Norman
Tes cernes, c'est naturel ?
Ben non ! C'est du maquillage
D'accord ! Okay
Sacré Norman 100% Naturel pour répondre à vos questions ?
C'est quoi ces cernes ?
On dirait que je suis en forme
Tu veux vraiment que je passe pour un mec qui a bien dormi ?
Norman comment fais-tu pour avoir toujours la classe comme ça au quotidien ?
Ben écoute je sais pas c'est naturel
Attends Norman c'est toi qui t'es posé ta propre question là
Non
Bah si c'est écrit
J'aimerais savoir si quand les gens te critiquent et t'insultent, ça te fait quoi ?
Ben évidemment ça me fait super plaisir
Mais c'est Norman ? Et Norman va te faire enculer !
Merci !
Et nique ta mère !
Attends allons boire un café
Est-ce que tu pourrais dire un mot en Créole pour moi stp ?
(parle en Créole) Pa ni pwoblèm
Lisse-toi les cheveux
Non
Ça c'est mort on va pas commencer à faire les gamins. Attends j'ai 27 ans. Je suis pas là pour faire des trucs de bébé et de maternelle.
Question suivante
Comptes-tu faire ...
Comptes-tu faire d'autres meet up à Grenoble par exemple
Bah écoute Emma, pourquoi pas et j'ai eu l'occasion de faire des meet up à Amiens, à Nantes, à Cannes, à Paris.
Donc, euh... Pourquoi pas prochainement, à Grenoble.
Salut, j'ai la coupe de Jeanne d'Arc
si tu étais un personnage de dessin animé lequel serais tu ?
bah moi j'aimerais bien être trunks de dragon ball z
vraiment extrêmement stylé
mais je sais très bien que c'est pas du tout ma ressemblance première
Et beaucoup de gens me disent que je ressemble à Sid, de l'Âge de glace
Beaucoup moins cool
Ça va mes petits mammifères
Les types de personnes que tu détestes, c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que t'aimes pas chez les gens ?
Ben j'aime pas trop les gens qui, quand ils parlent, papillonnent des yeux
Ils te parlent sans te regarder
Bonne question ! Bon, c'est vrai que moi, quand j'ai commencé...
...ce métier, euh...
Ben vous êtes où les gars ?
Préfères-tu monter des vidéos ou monter sur scène ?
Ben écoute j'aime les deux autant
J'aime autant faire les deux. J'espère que je pourrai longtemps continuer à...
... à pratiquer ces deux passions entre guillemets
Penses-tu avoir une chance de gagner The Voice ?
WTF ?
Alors je vois pas trop comment je pourrais gagner The Voice puisque je ne participe pas du tout à l'émission
[C'est la danse des canards]
OK j'ai adoré ta voix, tu chantes super bien
Donc c'est très simple : dans mon équipe, j'ai décidé de prendre pas toi, mais Norman
Un mec qui fait des vidéos sur Youtube
Ça n'a aucun rapport avec l'émission, mais c'est mon choix
Voilà merci à tous !
Qu'est-ce que ça donne toi avec une barbe ou une moustache au feutre ?
C'est archi-mort. On a déjà fait les cheveux, stop.
Si tu devais faire une émission de téléréalité, laquelle choisirais-tu ?
Ben aucune
Je trouve que chacune de ces émissions...
... est de l'énorme merde, vraiment
Je n'en ferai... jamais... de ma vie
As-tu déjà eu un groupe de musique ?
Alors j'en ai eu plusieurs. Je fais de la musique depuis longtemps.
Bon là, avec les vidéos et les spectacles,
j'ai un petit peu ralenti
Mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu plusieurs groupes de musique, notamment un où je chantais, en effet
Je faisais de la chanson française un petit peu comique
Donc pour ceux que ça intéresse, ça s'appelait Monsieur Lingure
Donc je vous mets un petit lien
As-tu déjà subi un traitement orthodontique ?
Putain, j'arrive pas à dire ce mot
"orthon"
Oui, j'ai déjà subi un traitement orthodontique
Voici la preuve
Ah oui, parce que quand j'étais petit j'avais les dents de l'âne de Shrek
Donc... voilà...
Bon maintenant je n'ai plus les dents de l'âne de Shrek, mais j'ai la gueule de Sid
Donc... c'est pas plus mal
Tu m'as repéré hein ? Je me suis kiffé là
Attends, c'est pas tous les jours qu'on a les cheveux de Rick de Walking Dead
Même si en vrai, il a pas trop cette chevelure. Je sais pas pourquoi je parle de Rick
J'ai vraiment la coupure de Trunks. Ça y est ! Je suis en mode Trunks
Je vais prendre une petite douche après, avec une clope
Une douche une clope, les deux en même temps
Je peux pas aller acheter une baguette de pain comme ça
Impossible
Si je sors dans la rue... On me dira "Attends, qu'est-ce que t'as là. T'es vraiment super beau gosse."
Ça me pose problème. J'aimerais pas, si tu veux, draguer toutes les femmes si facilement
Question suivante
Veux-tu m'épouser ? Nan je déc'
Ah le truc carrément vexant quoi
Pourquoi as-tu oublié le verbe dans ton pseudo Twitter ?
C'est que Twitter, t'as pas la possibilité de mettre trop de lettres
Alors dans "Norman fait des vidéos", j'ai dû enlever un mot
Donc ça fait "Norman des vidéos"
Cette explication est beaucoup trop sérieuse, et un peu chiante
Alors on va passer à une autre question
S'il te restait plus qu'un mot à dire dans ta vie, quel serait-il ?
Euh, je pense que ça serait le mot "SUCE"
Norman, vous êtes en retard
Euh... Suce
Comment ça "suce" ?
Ben "Suce" !
Pourquoi pas...
Oh suce !
Mmm... suce !
Où iras-tu sur scène en 2015 pour ton spectacle ? Et quand ?
Ben, je vous mets mon planning, voilà.
Je fais une tournée dans toute la France
Au printemps dans plein de grandes villes, enfin dans plein de villes
De villes pas forcément grandes, je vais partout
Et puis après 35 dates complètes à Paris, il reste quelques dernières places disponibles du 10 au 25 avril à Bobineau
Allez viendez ! Hésitez pas à regarder le planning et à venir me voir si vous avez envie
Chuis hyper marrant. C'est abusé
Voilà, ma vidéo est terminée. Merci de l'avoir regardée. N'hésitez pas à vous abonner à ma chaîne YouTube.
Et moi, ben je vais aller tout simplement me faire refriser les cheveux
Est-ce que quelqu'un a un re-friseur ?
Hein ?
Un re-friseur de cheveux
Je vais rester comme ça toute ma vie ?
Mais nique ta mère wesh !
Allez ciao !